e
okay I'm going to open the meeting of
the uh health and Human Services
oversight
individual uh and uh we do not have a
quorum but uh that's okay CH I'd like to
hen jolly good fellow fellow from the
Milbank
foundation
with
associate yes to make the report good
morning good morning um and best wishes
from commissioner Weaver who of course
is at Governor's commission which seems
to have found a way to conflict with us
um
frequently um but we thought today for
the commissioner's update we talk a
little bit about uh a topic first you
know a lot about which is the the YDC
rebuild and then also go into a little
bit more detail for the record about the
system of care assessment work that
associate commissioner Tilly um is
helping Spearhead and builds on many of
the conversations around uh building out
our Behavioral Health System and um and
in particular increasing uh alternatives
to residential treatment which you've
been also quite deep on so good
morning so first on the uh YDC rebuild
so we have been working very hard since
selecting The Architects um to build the
new Youth Development Center facility
it's been about a month intensive
process of Designing a state-of-the-art
architecturally secure therapeutically
oriented facility um that is very much
first of its kind in the US for uh
avoiding a highly Correctional approach
and instead uh leveraging a a
therapeutically centered one um and as
part of that it will be located on the
same campus as Hamstead hospital and
residential facility um in Hamstead New
Hampshire um in a very good neighborhood
I might add of course and so it has been
this intensive process um actually come
to think of it it's almost closer to a
year of design development um and we're
now at the at the stage of uh actual
construction documents being finalized
those will be posted for prospective um
construction vendors to view uh on the
basically the very beginning of August
um and that gives bid biders about a
month to decide and to prepare their
bids um and then those bids are due in
uh September or October I forget the
exact date with the goal of making a
November governor and council meeting to
bring the contract forward um gives us a
little bit of wiggle room recognizing
that the arpa dollars need to be
encumbered by the end of this calendar
year um construction will then begin
immediately uh and we expect final
completion by the summer of
2026 um allowing the closure of the
current Sno Services Center and movement
into the new facility thereafter so um
so lots of great work going on it's been
highly collaborative um you of course uh
representative Pearson serve in a number
of capacities including on our DHHS
convened stakeholder advis committee um
we've been um having a lot of
conversations also with Senator bird
cell's um Community impact commission
around the variety of issues from Land
water safety programming Staffing
traffic and every other imaginable um
impact and I think are committed to
maintaining that that process of
collaboration but also really engaging
with our teams on the most um effective
Staffing and uh training model to make
this place uh one of of great um
habilitation and healing um and setting
youth on a on a very bright uh path
forward um and so happy to take any
questions on that before I hand it over
to associate commissioner Telly by
encumbered how is that defined so the
funds have to be actually in contract
with a cont yep so there has to be a
contract signed with a construction
build also uh when the construction
documents are posted say ballpark August
one will that be open to the public to
look at absolutely yeah those documents
will all be and it's and I would suggest
you send to me and more especially
Senator birdell since she is the uh Town
interface
chair um the a quick easy link so that
when people uh politely ask questions
about about this we can tell them here's
where you go to look for the docs
absolutely okay good thank you any other
questions on the center okay next topic
great over to good
morning thank you good morning thank you
chair thank you big house uh full house
today for a presentation so um I have
the opportunity today to talk a little
bit about our children's Behavioral
Health System of care and how we're
setting a path towards a new s so that
we sometimes call that system of care so
2.0 um before I get there I want to do a
little history and then sort of come
back to where we are right now so this
session the department had the privilege
of tracking just shy of 680 bills we
provided fiscal analysis on about 185 of
those bills on a huge array of topics
from privacy confidentiality Health Care
child care that you're going to hear
more about cannabis all sorts of fun
things um but some of the most important
policy conversations in my mind really
centered on Mental Health um the child
protection system and our children's
residential um care so for years the
legislature has recognized and has been
supportive of the needs of kids and
their families um sometimes in Leaps and
Bounds and sometimes in small increment
increments we have built we have sort of
put together this system that we have
right now in my role previously in
public health you know I have been
around for several permutations of this
development quite frankly for decades in
2010 I was on the original behavoral
Health collaboratives partnering with
Advocates philanthropy providers the
department and that laid the foundation
of sort of the hopes and dreams of what
a system of care could be we learned a
lot from families we learned a lot about
what was working but really more
importantly what wasn't working and
that's where we really started to build
this out by 2016 we um sp sp 534 created
RSA
135f which required the state to develop
and maintain this integrated
comprehensive Service delivery approach
for children's Behavioral Health needs
that is the first time you really start
seeing system of care in legislation is
right about 2016 after that we have the
10e mental health plan in the 2018 area
with more investments from the Governor
from the legislature and by 2019 we had
even more legislation signed and we
connected that system of care to other
child serving systems like DCF so fast
forward to today um and throughout all
those long hearings and longer
amendments that we all sat through this
session um we I believe we have
strengthened and started to refine the
system of care um but you still for
those of you who aren't in this work all
the time like you and I are um there may
be some questions about what what
exactly is that um you know and so I'd
like to just spend just a couple of
minutes reminding folks about this thing
called a system of care in that it is
both a strategy and a particular set of
services it offers an integrated
delivery structure for comprehensive
Behavioral Health Services it is also a
work in progress um on the handout in
front of you um you'll see a DI diagram
that has been used often to visualize
what a tiered and coordinated system
that organizes services and exp um
supports into five layers so you'll see
what that looks like that is a document
that we've used many times before at
least a visual that we've used many
times that talks about um the from the
lower levels of tier tier one to higher
levels of intensity which is tier five
which is an acute psychiatric hospital
setting so across that entire system
so um what I'm going to do this morning
is we know that needs have changed since
those early days in the 2000s notably in
the volume and the complexity um and so
we need to ensure that this system that
we've envisioned that Circle those five
tiers is able to continue to grow and
continue to respond to those needs of
families so I'm going to walk you
through what we have give you an update
on what's the work ahead of us and of
course we would love to to hear your
feedback so Where Do We Begin and and
I'm going to just walk very quickly
through those five tiers because I think
it's important because often times in
legislation amendments we throw numbers
out oh that's like a one or that's like
a two or that institution is a level
five and I think that that can become um
I think it's time to step back and just
sort of go what how do we put that into
context what does that really mean so
again tier one is exactly what you would
expected to be it is the entrylevel um
area of the system it's where you go it
is screening an assessment it's work
with your pediatricians your family docs
your schools and where basic assessment
happens basic screening happens um for
General Health and Wellness this is much
like your well child visit you know you
go you get your shots you learn about
all sorts of things or even as an adult
you go for your annual physical and you
talk about your overall wellness and so
we need to support that we can't just
start thinking about the system of Care
at residential care we actually have to
start at this very beginning thinking
about what happens in those trusted
relationships with your health care
provider and your family so that's where
we start in tier one by tier two you you
sort of start moving from screening to
treatment um tier 2 Services include
outpatient treatments that address
specific mental health conditions like
depression anxiety perhaps aggressive
behavior in a kid kiddo um these
Services can also include alation
treatments for um to treat a youth's uh
alcohol or drug use these services are
provided by Behavioral Health
Specialists or agencies sometimes within
the context of a school who are by staff
who are specifically trained or
credentialed to provide that type of
treatment so again one step up from your
pediatrician set you know having a
conversation about your child's Wellness
into treatment that is actually about a
specific condition um tier 2 Also may
have some case management As you move
forward but again you know if you think
about it in the medical um healthc care
system I I go to my doctor I get
screened for diabetes I may get treated
for diabetes this is sort of at that
level where I'm treated for that
condition yes what uh level of direct
oversight does the department have on
these agencies and schools who are now
intervening at step two sure so at step
two I mean that I you know the
department may have some role in there
um but it would be through our regular
systems whether that's the community
Mental Health Centers whether it's the
federally qualified Health Centers
that's really the standard of care and
that's the the degree to which we would
have oversight we have supported special
projects such as um you know uh
interesting collaborations with
federally qualified Health Center like
Amis Health who is now providing that
care within the school so we have some
contractual oversight but we expect that
everyone follows the standard of care
that they would have that they have for
their particular certification or level
of care it's good to expect it do you
supervise it to make sure your
expectations in the same way in the same
way that we don't oversee necessarily if
you get the standard of care for your
diabetes okay so you know it's at that
level standard care outpatient we have a
relationship with some programs um but
really the expectation is that folks are
following um what they are credential to
do and within the scope of their it
would it would be akin to what I know in
the medical world absolutely okay thank
absolutely so you know then we get a
little bit closer and then we get to a
place where the department has a closer
touch to this which is around tier three
and this is really what I like to think
about tier three is where we prevent
escalation one and two is just standard
of care getting the care that you need
in the community Guided by a family in
the case of children Guided by the
family they're getting the care that
they need in a routine outpatient
setting by tier three we start looking
at complex situations where families
caregivers and providers are doing what
they can but something might not be
working tier three services are meant to
bring families and youth together with
all of the people in their support
networks in their clinical support
networks and their home support networks
to meet their needs and you know this is
where we start seeing this idea of a
wraparound this is where we start
wrapping services around a family they
are more intensive this is where the
Department of Health and Human Services
our Bureau of children's behavioral
health is more likely to get involved
and have a a closer touch on those
Services um so and I think for me as you
know I step into this work this is where
we need to spend a lot of attention
because it's these Services these
wraparound that are happening within the
community within a family's you know
keeping kids at home um and out of more
restrictive care this this is where we
need to invest in our promising
approaches um and make sure that this
work is done really well because again
it it's designed to prevent escalation
into higher needs and quite frankly into
what's tier four which is Residential
Treatment you know there is um I want to
say that residential treatment is an
important part it you know it is part of
our budget conversations it is part of
our policy conversations it's critical
need for some families and for some
youth um but this is where Services
become intensive quite frankly also
expensive you know the goal is always to
keep youth in their families and within
their communities but there are times
when youth may just need to go into a
residential program to be safe and to
get the treatment they need would this
be Hamstead Hospital not yet no not the
new building the existing building so so
yes to some degree so tier four this is
where we get some numbers sort of flying
around so this is tier four in our
system but within this tier four if you
look at little document there are
multiple levels of care there are five
levels of care so yes the prtf at
Hamstead would be level five but there
are four levels before you even get to
Hamstead prtf okay um could I have a
list at some point of what descriptors
of each level is because last time I
wandered through my neighborhood Mental
Health Center um somebody was so excited
because we're retrofitting this to go
from level two to level three and all I
could say was that's nice yeah
absolutely I mean level one is usually
treatment programs where um we are
working towards older youth often that
have been in the dcyf system and they're
becoming more independent aging out of a
children's services program and so this
is where there may not be ex um
extensive therapeutic um work but really
just working on transitioning kids out
into the community as they get older
we've had about 16 kids in that level of
service in back in May um then we get to
level two which again is Residential
Services these are 24 hours a day you
know supervision 24/7 they include a
combination of targeted Residential
Treatment Services and community-based
treatment services you then sort of ramp
up to level three again all in this
level four box but you ramp up to level
three services and this is um treatment
that includes you know really structured
behavioral health treatment and
educational programming provided within
the facility to and it often what you
want to do is you put that investment so
that ultimately you can get kids back
down back into closer to their community
and then when you get into levels four
and five that's when you get into
intensive Subacute acute care um
residential care for kids that's where
you start getting to the prtf that is
located at Hampstead so again lots of
levels we're happy to provide you a a
little cheat sheet that sort of talks
you through it but it's been my
experience that you know I think in many
of these conversations we start throwing
numbers around and I think it probably
can be mindboggling to anyone who's not
in this world every single day I would
call it an education enhancement device
but cheat sheet will work that's great
so you know again level five prtf
psychiatric residential treatment
facilities they provide immediate safety
physical and mental health assessment
and monitoring they provide medication
when it's needed and treatment for those
kids who are experiencing a serious
psychiatric emergency you know this
really should be at the very highest
level of need um in may we had 11
children um New Hampshire children who
were receiving level five care so and
then then so that was still tier four of
our system of care and then you get to
tier five which is the acute
hospitalization Hamstead hospital that
is for that acute level of care
hopefully a shorter time in duration
where we're really stabilizing children
who are in immediate need and have a
very high level of Acuity of care okay
question on that because when I did that
walk around of Hamet hospital they were
retrofitting a unit and they did use an
ascending number we're moving it from I
don't know 2 to three or 3 to four so
does that fit under tier four descriptor
or tier five I'm not sure the timing was
this pretty
recent was was was this in the past year
or longer ago okay so the renovations um
you're talking about I don't know the
reference to the number it probably had
to do with a sort of architectural
security but two of the impatient units
were were renovated to have more um
basically to remove drop ceilings to
avoid um youth pushing up the ceiling
tiles and having issues so it just seen
as a safer um Improvement and also some
effects to reduce some of the noise
echoing so it's it's it was some
intensive um construction work but it
was it's still within the impatient
environment it could well be that that's
what the the numbers referred to is yeah
perhaps I haven't heard any numbers on
that but that's different than the the
Myriad levels uh that the associate
commissioner is talking about the cheat
sheet would be welcome yes absolutely
more happy to do that so you know I
think this is all oh I'm
sorry yes representative Merchant thank
you thank you thank you Mr chair I just
want to be clear where I'm think we're
going but when I look at the word
behavioral versus mental health I think
of them as being really distinctly
different and when I think of mental
health I think of something that's
really rooted into a medical condition
like psychosis schizophrenia whatever
else is going on which is beyond the
individual ability to control it I
alluded
to type 2
diabetes you can do a L with type 2
diabetes with the treatment but you
could do a lot more with prevention by
changing one's lifestyle so in this
process here are we focused
on children that we need to treat
because we doing up on the prevention
side I mean part of it comes down
to family and modeling of behavior and
if you have children that are raised in
a family with dynamics that are not
healthy they will eventually transcend
themselves into behavioral issues so
what are we doing to help the family the
children a very young age to begin to
understand what is appropriate modeling
of what's appropriate behavior versus
waiting until they get to be a teenager
when it's sort of out of control so
that's what I'm trying to get to in here
how does this address that that that is
like the million-dollar question
representative Merchant so I think in
here that's where the efforts that I
feel like we need to have even stronger
work or more coordinated work is sort of
in those Beginnings that tier one tier 2
area where you're working with families
very early on from Early Childhood
you're providing opportunities for
support for families Family Support
parent education home visiting programs
um we uh we also have some Early
Childhood wraparound programs for uh
youth at the very young stage who are
exhibiting behavior that is concerning
but we also know that we want to make
sure that we are reducing any impacts of
trauma um many of the children who are
within our children's system of care are
also in our division for children youth
and services they have been impacted by
trauma in their own life by Family
instability so this is where really
where it does take a village this is
where concrete supports for families
making sure that they have the care so
that they can provide the best care for
their their own children um and have uh
supportive environments to um ensure
that we can address some of those
behaviors you know your question around
Behavioral Health we use that very
consciously because we know that there
are both mental health conditions which
certainly can um be experienced by even
very young children but we also know
that there's some behavioral context as
well as issues with things like
substance use so we want to put that all
with under that same umbrella because
the system Sim similarly works in the
way that you want to do the preventative
work early on and then get into the more
um acute needs as you you know hopefully
prevention thank it's very
helpful where I'm sort of trying to get
to is that in partnering with people and
the I think individuals or professions
that could be extremely valuable here
and we have another discussion coming up
in this later is the role of the school
nurse my wife spent 25 years in the
school system and she could articulate
the students who had issues way before
they became a problem so what are we
doing to engage the school nurse and
help them become part of the solution to
at least get either identify the student
who needs help or get them to the
resources need help because it's a
vastly underutilized resource in our
system is there are the and years of
what's really going on out there both in
behavioral issues food insecurity issues
they're for the most part of what I call
a safe trusted individual within the
school system they don't judge students
they don't give grades they're the ones
that give the Band-Aids hold their hands
so what are we doing from the
Department's point of view to fully
engage with a school nurse sure so I I
think you're you really hit an important
point they are clearly an
underutilized set of Professionals for
us within the department individually
when we get to those areas of wraparound
care you know our teams are deeply
engaging with individual School nurses
on individual children's care that
absolutely is happening I think there's
a lot of opportunity though to even step
back a little bit and really engage
earlier in that process in some of those
ideas around prevention and early
screening school health is remarkably
important and those nurses are on the
front line you know I always go back to
my experience in public health we could
not have done what we did without school
without nurses you know we were on the
phones with nurses every single day and
you're absolutely right they um fill
that void they make they know who who
had dinner or who had dinner or who had
breakfast before they came to work they
know who has clean clothes to wear they
know who's experiencing problems they
know when someone come you when a kiddo
comes with a tummy ache that that might
represent a whole number of issues and
so you're absolutely right I think
there's a lot of opportunity for us to
be more intentional in the way that we
work with the school nurse the school
nurse world even in a much more
preventative way than when we work with
them on a specific
child so we've got this fancy system and
I don't want to take too much of your
time what we're really excited about
though is um we are looking at the need
to to relook to assess where our system
is today we have seen that um you know
know we all want kids to be safe healthy
thriving in their communities we want to
reduce the number of kids that are in
need of residential inpatient treatment
I think that's a common goal for all of
us we want to improve the Alternatives
and step down from and to out of home
placements including the most complex
youth for whom specialized trauma
informed care supports are really needed
so we have put our heads together to say
to to work with Partners out um
specifically with the University of
Connecticut to help us look at where we
are today give us a point intime
assessment understand where we are in
relation to our goals but also
understand where we are in relation to
the experiences that we're having right
now we can all think about the traumas
that we have collectively experienced
since when we first put those in those
initial building blocks of the system of
care together we have lived through a
global pandemic we lived through an
opioid EP a pandemic as well we have a
different set of constraints and
challenges in front of us our schools
are are experiencing different
challenges our Workforce is experiencing
different challenges all slightly change
from when we originally you know first
started drawing that circle with those
five tiers the other reason we're
interested in in thinking about a path
forward and looking at sort of a system
of care 2.0 is really the timing um
we're going to start where're we hope to
have a contract in place in July um and
you can probably put that together in
your own mind why this fall this summer
in the fall is particularly critical to
us because it's really as we're starting
to tee up what we need in terms of
budget and policy requests for the new
bium so we are prepared uh we're working
on entering into an agreement with the
University of Connecticut to conduct an
assessment these experts at the
University of Connecticut have helped
New Hampshire and many other states work
through their own challenges in creating
a comprehensive system of care they are
going to be tasked with learning what's
working what needs Improvement um
hearing from policy makers hearing from
Community Based agencies hearing from
families also to understand what's
working what's not working and together
with DHHS and all of these Partners
we're going to develop some
recommendations priorities and an and
what the implementation steps are that
will align with our fundamental visions
and goals around system of care so by
2025 we hope we're going to take those
initial findings to design and maybe
redesign the infrastructure the people
processes places technology policies all
of those things that we would need to
implement to to create any system design
recommendations and new ways potentially
to contract with vendors um
opportunities for new policy
opportunities for new financing
strategies the financing piece is really
important to all of us it's of
considerable interest to me in my role
and um I think as we enter this new bium
that bium and that budget is going to
require some hard decisions and some
fiscal responsibility on behalf of all
of us and so we need to spend some time
about looking how does how will our
system fit within those parameters so um
we have an exciting year ahead of us um
I hope that you will help us as we go
through this assessment I think it takes
some continued intention and attention
to mature and evolve this system uh we
have a really great dedicated State
staff and we have leaders and we have
great policy Advocates and partners in
the community who have put in long hours
and and I know that we can count on them
to grow and adapt as we move forward um
we're really lucky to have them and
we're lucky to have all of you who also
help us go through those and guide us
through that process so you know I will
close out by saying that there are
thousands of children that are depending
on us to get this right um and so I look
forward to all of our continued
partnership and doing that as we work
through these new assessments I'm very
glad we have a representative of finance
committee with us today because you're
making your your wish list which becomes
my wish list too my question is that I
see an overlap here between children and
family law and Health and Human Services
committee uh coincidentally I overlap
that too and um if there is
legislation that you think you might
need to be filed this fall please link
up those who are interested uh I don't
write bills um as you know which is a
good thing but I hope bills along and uh
if there are people that any of us would
be interested in working with um uh
please let us know because we'd like to
throw our weight behind it thank you
thank you so much we absolutely need and
and appreciate all of the partnership
that we've had with all of our policy
makers I think you speak to the trifecta
of Finance child and family law and HHS
you know those are the the Committees
that we work most closely with and our
job this summer is to do the homework
and do the assessment so that we can
come back with plans that make sense
thank you any further
questions representative
King thank you Mr chairman um I don't
know I'm trying to form a question here
um I I love what you're doing I I I love
um uh because well I love it because we
have a big need in families today and I
was just talking to representative
Merchant in the hallway about um I'm not
running next time and so what are you
going to do and um and so somebody like
me who's not going to be a legislator
and writing bills to help you out how
can somebody like myself help your
organization that is a great question I
don't know if Deputy Commissioner wants
to be thinking about that as well but I
I'll start and and look forward to you
to add in you know I I think there are a
number of Our Community Partners that
need um Advocates and supporters whether
those that are provide those
preventative levels of care those home
visi those programs Our Family Resource
Centers our um and then all the way up
through our community mental health
centers need more active volunteers and
supporters within there folks that
understand the issue I think even just
translating for your friends in your
community what this is about and why
there is a need I think all of us have a
mental model or a sort of a narrative
around kids these days and I think it's
much more complex and we need everyone
to be able to speak to that um to be
able to speak to the needs and the fact
that there's hope that this isn't a lost
cause that we have a system of care it's
important it's important to have an
acute Hospital psychiatric hospital but
the reason to have that is so that we
can put Youth and families onto a path
of healing and hope and and really
optimism and reintegration within their
community so that's a big wide answer
it's not a specific ask I don't know
depy if you I mean I think I would just
add that it seems like in today's um
political politically divis divisive
climate that U mental health and youth
mental health remains one of these
unicorns of areas of bipartisan
nonpartisan engagement and I think it's
really important that we protect that
Common Ground space of saying right now
this is an area that almost every
legislator can get behind and I think
how do we use that salience to move a
little bit beyond as you heard um the
ass commissioner describ you know
facilities and programs into real
systems change which um cost money
requires um going against the status quo
and I think that type of the political
Savvy that you've Acquired and the
ability to engage in common ground um
work will serve us all well so thanks
for that offer though I would say to the
representative that in previous editions
of the House calendar there has been an
announcement about how uh at a county
level at a state level there are all of
these different boards that a person
could volunteer for that would be one
thing to look at secondly as I looked
over the Secretary of State's list of
who has signed up to run there were
several people who vowed I will never do
it again and took a term out and the
wife said yes you will and so we may see
see anything else
and the chair recognizes Maryanne barter
and Jesse
Davis advisory Council on Child Care
annual
report and please introduce yourself to
us and to the listening audience the
neelson writings for this committee have
been hopeful so you're on camera I'm
Jesse Davis I'm the bureau chief of
Child Development and headart
collaboration
hi I'm maryan barter I'm the chair of
the New Hampshire childcare advisory
Council so thank you for um thank you
for your leadership and thank you for
having us here
today the childcare advisory oh and this
is the handout we're looking at is it
yes good looks like this this hand
that's the last page but
yes it looks like this on the front
page so the childcare advisory council
is a legislatively enacted group that
exists really to to advise on the
affordability and the accessibility of
childcare in New Hampshire so that's our
lens we're of course concerned about
things like the quality of child care um
you know whether parents are getting
their needs met all of those things are
really really important to us but our
priority and the lens that we use is
accessibility and affordability and the
work that we've done has really been to
with those guiding principles to ensure
that we have a steady supply of child
care that meets the needs of children
meets the needs of parents in New
Hampshire so our work for the last year
has been primarily regulatory so one of
the burdens that that one of the things
we realized that was keeping people from
being entering the child care field
staying in the child care field were
things like confusion around regulations
confusion around um zoning and um
different fire codes for different towns
things like that so a lot of the work
that we've done for the last year has
been around addressing those issues and
seeing if we can make it easier for
child providers to function in the state
we work closely with um the child care
licensing unit to um they actually
reached out to us and we developed a
workg group to go through the child care
licensing regulations line by line to
see if we could not weaken them but at
least streamline them get them to the
point where um they were not over a 100
pages long they were not I mean we're
humans doing tasks remembering a 100
pages of regulations is going to be very
very difficult but we went through to
kind of streamline them to look at
things that were in rule but maybe
should just be in policy that um if a
center has a procedure for handling
something well maybe licensing doesn't
really have to have a rule around that
they just need to know that you have a
procedure for handling it we've just
completed that work it took slightly
over a year and very soon that'll be
going out for public comment we also
engaged heavily with um the special
committee on child care there was a
representative from the childcare
advisory council at every one of those
meetings to ensure that the legisl that
was being considered in the state was
something that's functioning for the
field and I will say one of the things
we take most seriously is that we do
speak for the field we hear from
providers every day we hear their
struggles we hear their triumphs and we
really want to make sure that their
stories are Amplified and and that
people in the state understand the
challenges and successes that that um
you have providers are facing we also
worked very closely with DHHS and our
partner Jesse Davis to implement
the um increased Child Care um um income
eligibility and so when
dhj announced that the eligibility for
child care scholarship was going to
increase and include many more families
um childcare advisory Council started
talking to Providers saying that's great
for families that's wonderful that
they'll be able to have child care more
affordable for their families but how do
we get you engaged with the process how
do we convince the provider that yes
you'll have to bill and yes it'll be a
little bit challenging but here's why
you should do that that was sort of our
work on this process and um it's been an
incredible year for the first time ever
we were awarded by the couch Foundation
enough funds to actually hire a director
and we've never had that before but
because we were asked to do so many
things it really helped kind of elevate
our work and make it possible for us to
take on some of these projects that were
really truly time consuming the rest of
the committee is really volunteer we're
we're stakeholders we're child I mean I
run a Child Care Agency um we are people
anything I don't really have much to add
other than I think that the work that
we're going to be doing this year to um
strengthen the current systems we have
and make it easier for families to um
become enrolled in scholarship and
easier for programs to engage in the
scholarship program is a priority goal
for
US Representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair and also
thank you taking the
question can you speak
to trying to create a more Dynamic
private public partnership in other
words when I look on page five and
looking at what's there for the return
on the
investment I don't think it should fall
completely on the state the
business Community industrial Community
Bia if you will has a tremendous amount
to gain by this so where are they in
teaming up with you folks on trying to
ensure that there's money put into the
system to help health uh child care
workers in the agencies do their job
because ultimately if you don't have
workers you don't have a job and you
don't have a business so there is some
logic to trying to team up with the
business Community as well as with the
state so where are we with a public
private partnership So currently um we
are engaging in business roundtables all
across the state to identify partners
and um the the new state plan calls out
these public private Partnerships and so
we will be exploring that um and
identifying those partners and those
communities who are willing to braid and
blend funds to solve this problem
actually follow up I'm sorry could I
speak to that sure so the childcare
advisory council is actually our biggest
concern is the amount of wages that
child care workers make they're low
they're lower than every other area in
New England um if you looked at a chart
we would be this glowing sort of
horrible statistic in the middle of it
and I completely agree with you and the
childcare advisory Council completely
agrees with you that child care has been
Pro been providing an unpaid benefit to
the business community for decades and
it is absolutely time for us to look at
our business partners and say we're in
this together how can you support us and
we actually do have a very concrete plan
that we're hoping to introduce as
legislation this fall to support to
create a fund to support the Child Care
Community specifically through wages and
benefits um I'm afraid Jesse does not
know very much about this plan it's
still in its implementation plan on
stage
but you know we've passed a lot of
legislation that helps child care you
know it's a little bit here and it's a
little bit there but when we look at the
real problem can people afford to do
this work can people raise their
families while doing this work the real
problem comes down to the money in the
pocket of providers and so how do we
look at that as a Statewide problem and
how do we look at that with our business
Community saying yes when I hire someone
you get to hire eight people and that is
a huge benefit to you so how do you
support my hiring someone and we we
absolutely do have a
plan the
other concern I have is how we sort of
balance child safety with portability
what I'm trying to get to is that we
need a certain amount of regulations to
protect the child but not so much that
we kill the business so therefore how do
we balance that between being sure the
child's safe but not so honorous on the
regulatory side that it becomes very
expensive for somebody who wants to run
a child care facility to comply with all
the rules and regulations we put in
there because it's just onerous and it
also gets to the point where the more
regulation in my opinion that you have
the more you squeeze out M and PAW
because they don't have the resources to
comply and deal with all the regulatory
issues 100 page document if you Mom and
P you're not going to go through it so
therefore you eliminate that out
completely out of the marketplace so how
do we balance child safety with
affordability and what can we do on the
regulatory side to help you folks
minimize the regulations that we think
we don't need but still need to have
child so I think our work with child
care licensing is really addressing this
so the work group that the childcare
advisory Council was able to put
together was actually providers
childcare providers there were
representatives from every region in the
state and there were representatives
from every type of child care that's not
true licensed child care that's
available in the states we had after
school programs we had family providers
we had Center providers so it really was
a very comprehensive group and we did go
through this line by line I completely
agree with you having 100 pages of
regulations
although I understand child safety and
how important it is it's discouraging
right you open this up and you're like
why on Earth would I do this to myself
um the childcare advisory Council has
been in talks with the um Community
Development Finance Authority to create
a document that would pull out the
family child care regulations so they
would have a much shorter document and
that was a little bit more um easily
understood and easily digestable and
then the center base so basically
dividing the the book we've not received
permission to do that yet but that is
part of our plan moving forward there's
no reason why a family provider needs to
know how to run an after school program
but so help me understand
what's in rules that create the issue
versus what's in statute statute the
department has have any choice to comply
with if it's a rule interpretation of
the statute is that part of what we need
to deal with on the legislative side
because if there are statutes that are
in play that are causing concerns for
the Department either in the
interpretation of and so forth then I
think Mr chairman legislatively we
should understand what those statutes
are and start to deal with it from the
leg set of side of the equation it's
primarily rule so there are a few
statutes but really in general Child
Care is implemented through rule I will
say we have a couple of things that are
really issues zoning and fire
regulations so an example of this would
be there's not any family child care in
conquered because of the zoning issues
and because of the fire regulations so
when you're looking at something like
that you're looking at a place like
conquer where I run an agency that has a
weight list that's over 200 children
long you know Child Care could
definitely lessen the burden for people
and how do we how do we address child
safety that we're worried about fire I
mean we're worried about fire
inspections we're worried about all of
families just
King yeah I guess I guess I guess this
is uh along the same lines as what
representative Merchant was talking
about and it was actually brought up in
the debate last night although I don't
know if anybody either one of them
actually addressed this but um the
workforce is is short
people and what I hear from a lot of
people is uh is one of the spouses is
staying home because it's actually
cheaper to stay home and not go um go go
to work and then have to pay and make
just a few dollars more than what
they're actually paying and so I I
couple that with one of your statements
that wages is one one of the
reasons
but knowing how business works and uh
supply and demand when you have a long
list of kids on a list and only a few
Supply
uh suppliers or
providers then you can end up jacking
the rates up and uh and it just seems
like we need to figure out how to get
more of these um uh child care providers
out there and and I I think back to when
my kids were small and I wanted my wife
to stay home with the kids we she
actually took kids in so I don't know if
there's a way of promoting grassroot
systems like that can you speak to that
sure I know the DHHS is also committed
to doing this work but childcare
advisory Council understands and truly
respects the the place that family child
care has in the child care ecosystem in
the state so it is really important and
part of the reason why we have such a
crisis in child care right now is
because so many family child care
programs have closed either because
zoning or Fire or the death of a
thousand paper cuts so absolutely that
is completely true um Child Care is
extraordinarily expensive I can use as
an example my own agency um so I spend
about 70% of our income on labor that
leaves 30% for insurance which is
incredibly expensive you know and
everything else that it takes to I mean
right this second I'm sure one of our
toilets is clogged right so all of that
stuff is extraordinarily expensive so it
is a really labor intensive industry and
it's just not going to get less
expensive so it's really I think for the
childcare advisory Council what our
concern is how do we invest wisely we
have limited funds right so ccdf has
limited funds the state has limited
funds so how do we invest these in the
smartest way possible to ensure that we
get the biggest bang for our buck and um
I think when you invest in people and
people who do the work that's the best
that's always going to be your best
investment representative King
anticipated something I was going to ask
let's say Mrs Smith for whatever reason
decides to stay home with her little one
but her cousin has a little one and
their friend from church has a little
one so now you have three little ones
staying over what could go wrong with
this well there are a few things that
could go wrong with this and I would
neither want the state to come in with
onerous regulations that would shut this
down or totally ignore the situ
situation in case there are genuine
Hazard some of which could be remediated
or this is not a fit person to have
other children in the home maybe not
even her own where is The Sweet Spot
there sure well for three children you
would not need a light to be licensed so
the state would not be coming in unless
you received Child Care development
funds in which case you would be visited
by the state um unfortunately when
you're talking about family child care
home the parents not unfortunately
regardless of the situation the parent
gets to decide who is the safest and
most appropriate caregiver for their
child right this is their baby they have
a lot of philosophies about how they
want their child raised they get to
choose who is the right caregiver
unfortunately sometimes that is someone
that the rest of us on the planet think
would be inappropriate but the break
spot is three the break the break spot
is now four if the governor signs at the
break spot will be
four irrespective of whether the other
three sets of parents individual parents
pay money or not correct so it would be
three children right now it's three
children who are not your own if soon it
will be four children who are not your
own so if I had a child I could take in
three other children and not be licensed
by the the parents of those other
children would be The Regulators in
effect they would be The Regulators good
thank
you representative Merchant thank you
clarification on the number of children
that are not own is there a limit on the
number of children you have that are are
your own that are your own yes so um we
my agency also sponsors something called
a CH child and adult care food program
and it it's kind of like school lunch um
we have a license exempt provider who
has three of her own children and cares
for three Community children so in her
program she has six children she's
operating legally three of them are her
own through your community so the
question is there a limit on the number
of children you can have that are your
own no I think you could have 47 of your
own children and as long as you only
have three Community children you are
licensed exemp it's the number of
children that are not your own that's
limitation corre okay thank you okay
then you need a consult from the mental
health department got commissioner T
Tilly steps in at that point but
yes anyone
else thank you so much for your
presentation
now Dr Angela MC Smith New England
College nursing program with somebody
who's not on my list but introduce
before good
morning I'm Angela MC Smith you must be
closer to the microphone
please Angela MC
Smith and I'm Emily Higgins I'm an
academic practice partner at conquered
hospital and oh yes I guess I should say
I'm the dean of Nursing and Health
College okay
ready all right well thank you for
inviting us here today to talk to you
about our um Innovative partnership but
our
Innovative I'm not talking loud enough
I'm not hearing well enough can you hear
me I can okay so I wanted to be able to
speak to just our program but also our
partnership with our um Hospital
Partners so um New England College back
in the um early spring of 2021 did a
listening tour of New Hampshire
hospitals to try to understand a little
bit about the needs of our HealthCare
Partners in the region and learned um
about the nursing shortage and um the
exacerbation that was the nursing
shortage being exacerbated by the
covid-19 um pandemic at the time I have
been a nurse for 24 years I was um an
academics the last 10 in a various in
various roles from clinical instructor
to full-time faculty to Dean and have um
learned a lot of lessons along the way
um I was asked by New England College to
consult on this idea about a Cooperative
education model in nursing um this model
has been used in the past um and in my
experience from the institution I used
to work at in Resort and Hospitality
management where business students
worked and um learned and um um um lived
all at this Resort in Vermont and so the
idea behind it was that students would
go into this Resort and they'd work in
all capacities and they would have their
instructors come to um the resort and
teach them and then of course they lived
there it was their residence and so um I
was asked to think about Nursing
education everything I knew and then
sort of everything that I have ever
wanted um and if I could create
something U really Innovative what would
that look like and so I thought about it
for a little while and um you know
there's not enough room in our hospitals
right now for our patients so you know
obviously our students can't live there
um really conference room space is a
little bit tight so we really can't send
our instructors there but the one thing
that we could really impact was
providing students with an authentic
experience in clinical and so what does
it really look like to be a registered
nurse how do I really um what are the
things I need to know the things I need
to do um the pillars of this program as
I was um I really had a blank slate and
sort of a Blank Stare on my face really
on July 12th 2021 thinking okay I really
need to figure this out um fortunately
for me on July I don't know 14th I um we
had an inaugural partner in conquered
hospital so I came to New Hampshire I
met with the team and we started working
on this together and so through this
process have been able to establish what
we'd like to call a designated education
partnership and so we are truly sharing
in the responsibility of educ ating our
future nursing Workforce and what does
that look like and so we are using the
earn as youlearn model where students
work um part of their education they
actually spend 30% of their education
immersed in a clinical setting in our
Hospital Partners throughout New
Hampshire they um earn money as an LNA
and also earn academic credit through
that process they spend um one clinical
shift a week during each Cooperative
experience working oneon-one with
Hospital partner um registered nurses
who are staff um NEC provides those
preceptors with an education um so they
essentially come from a preceptor
perspective where they would normally be
working with um new graduates or with
new employees um orienting them to the
hospital to now clinical teachers so we
spend the time with them in the very
beginning to help educate them on how to
work with our nursing students and in
conjunction with that they're also they
have a clinical faculty member who is
there on site during each of their RN
precepted shifts to help support not
just the students education but to also
help support the preceptor because we'd
like to call this a preceptor student
team a care team and so what this looks
like is um very similar to to what
diploma programs used to look like um
where it's an internship practicum type
model but instead of having that resered
to the end of the program it's right
from the very beginning and so so I was
talking about the pillars and so the
nursing Workforce shortage is really
where I was leading from and I wanted to
be able to impact that in several ways
and the very first way was providing the
hospitals with LNA support year round
because without them care would not be
able to happen in hospitals and there
was such a big um need for them and so
that became part of our
program the other way that I really
wanted to impact um the nursing shortage
in New Hampshire was instead of in a
traditional nursing model where nursing
students will um spend some of their
clinical time let's say at conquered
Hospital they'll spend some time at um
Portsmith or Parkland or name you know
insert Hospital name and they move
around a lot in their clinical practice
and they don't necessarily get a sense
of Jesus might be where I want to work
they don't have enough time to really
experience the system and so in our
model our students are immersed in one
Hospital partner site for three years
and so right from the very beginning
they are LNA employees at our Hospital
partner as hospital employees part of
the benefit is that academic um work
time goes towards their academic credit
and they're there for three years and so
they get to experience different they
have three years vested when they
graduate they're part of the choosing of
where do I maybe want to work we get
very strategic around this student lives
in this sort of um demographic area so
maybe they want to work at conquered
Hospital maybe we should put them at
Port Smith so that because they live
down by the Sea Coast and we want them
to stay in New Hampshire that was really
The Hope um the other way to impact this
is by by the nursing shortage is by
giving them a truly authentic experience
throughout their Nursing education in
that transition to practice right after
they graduate in that first year we lose
between I think it's 30 and 37% of
nurses in that first year of practice
because they don't know what it is
actually like to be a nurse until they
get into practice and do it and they're
like I didn't sign up for this well
that's good and bad right so but now it
happens sort of at the beginning of our
program so we've had to build in some
supports for them and it also tells them
right away is this something that I
really want to spend three years or and
it helps us offset them to another area
that they might want to work so it it
it's um hopefully preserving that in
that on that end but it's also a
professional develop M opportunity for
the preceptors so in partnership with
the hospitals providing preceptors with
that additional
education so that they can provide
students with a really good experience
but it will perpetuate hopefully that
preceptor mentality and those preceptors
will precept again our students will
precept and precept again and then we'll
be able to hopefully move a model
similar to this out to other schools of
Nursing in the state because everybody
right now um I was fortunate in
developing this program at a perfect
time I was developing this program when
all of the standards were changing and I
could go with the most up toate
standards and um sort of philosophies
around accreditation and um the Board of
Nursing has done a lot of innovative
things since I've come to New Hampshire
not because of me but it's just I'm a
lucky timing um
and so other programs in other schools
of nursing are all wonderful and we do
have a great um Nursing education um
system in New Hampshire but everybody is
changing to this new system they have
they're starting to have to change their
curriculum and move into these
directions and so we're hoping to really
grow this into not just um an NEC thing
but a New Hampshire nurs in thing um
similar to the board of nursing right
now um there's a pilot study that um
we're working through um at Portsmith
Hospital the exter nurse externship
program which would be great if we could
make that a permanent um thing so that
it can be implemented at other hospitals
not just in one area um so I asked Emily
to come because um working with her for
the last 3 years um we have some um
results um from our first cohort of
students and some of the impacts that
this has had on conquered hospital um in
general so I'll just turn this over to
you thank
you uh so some of the key results of our
program in our first class we had a
reduction and sorry for the small font
on your papers but um so we had a
reduction in LNA Staffing vacancy rates
from 20.8 FTE deficit it to 5.8 um we
also had 71% of them stay on as per DM
through their dactic semester so they
were still working and contributing to
the LNA Workforce at conquered hospital
and we also surveyed our preceptors and
it we had really positive results and I
think um giving back to the profession
and teaching the students for those who
weren't quite ready to like take on a
new grad um give satisfaction to our
preceptors which will keep them in the
field as we know we lost a lot so I'm
also a Adjunct professor for nhti and I
could see uh partnering with the ccsnh
system and their nursing programs I know
a lot of um students are second time
students so maybe they were in
Babysitting and now they want to be a
nurse or what have you um and they tend
to stay in New Hampshire so I could see
them wanting to work as alanas and stay
on perdm and we could like Branch into
that Realm um with the ccsnh uh
community colleges for nursing too
but couple things as I shared with you
before the meeting um I am chief
executive officer of a facility in
Kingston that combines family practice
medicine counseling and massage and we
have people uh both at the um
osteopathic physician level and also
nursing level do rotations with us so
I'm keenly interested in this you may be
aware that if you go up Huntington
Avenue in Boston you'll bump into a
facility called
Northeastern and they know about
Cooperative education yeah it's a
wonderful model and secondly you may not
know that uh 50 years ago as a young
Episcopal Deacon visiting hospitals I
could tell you in five minutes who was
in a college program versus who was in a
old tradition school of nursing program
and being the kind of mind I have I
often thought why couldn't we have the
best of both so you're 50 years in
coming but thank you for coming this can
be wonderful this kind of Cooperative
education that um when I was a theology
Professor we had with some of our
Seminary students on the way to
ordination not just three years of
academics and now out in the real world
but overlapping integrative so I think
this is a model that picks up both of
the
Traditions uh and could be variously
implemented in many places right um I
just wanted to um Express so last our
students began their first Cooperative
in the summer term so last summer I
spent a lot of time at conquered
hospital because I wanted to make sure
sometimes you know you just have to make
sure that you're what you think is going
to be good actually is and it was really
interesting to see that our students
were the same as any nursing student on
their first day of clinical they show up
they're terrified they get off the
elevator their knees are knocking they
don't know what to do with themselves
they don't know how to introduce
themselves to a patient um they're
afraid to like expose anybody to listen
to Heart or lungs they're just not quite
sure what to do with themselves um and
so we work with them through that but I
I can honestly say that watching them
move from that knee knocking scared to
death you know student nurse on the
elevator to just week six the learning
that they have it's what I want them to
take care of me independently six weeks
in no that AB no that's not what I'm
saying but what I'm saying is that
they're
learning because they are exposed to
everything and so like with all of the
standards changing we're less focused on
okay I need to do this skill I need to
do this skill I need to do this skill
they're more focused
on watching their preceptor being
team C1 do one teach one you know that
kind of a model um giving them a
three-year orientation into the
profession and really nurturing them and
looking at it from a systems perspective
so rather than eight students with one
clinical instructor like in a
traditional program on one unit where
that clinical instructor has to be at
the bedside for every RN scope of
practice thing which delays care it
doesn't give them it delays their time
management they are being exposed to
something that's not accurate in
practice and
so and you find that you have these
clusters of nursing students sort of
hanging around not really learning in
this model they're connected to the hip
of their preceptor if the preceptor is
moving they're moving they may not
understand initially what they're doing
but they pick it up really quick and
they reflect on their preceptor practice
for the
first well 14 weeks they're reflecting
on that preceptor practice because they
need to start to understand that this
was a problem this is what they did this
is how they fixed it then we
re-evaluated and then they start to do
it themselves one thing we have learned
having had students for 25 years early
on one of the students said on the one
hand and I like anything that begins
with on the one hand because you know
there's at least one more hand coming on
the one hand there's advantages to doing
one month rotations all over the place
on the other hand could I come back for
two more rotation
here because it's after the first
rotation you start to go deeper deeper
deeper into the place you're at
otherwise you're skimming the cream
times 6 8 10 12 rather than going in
depth times 2 or three so I commend the
fact that you're not sending them out to
all kinds of different places for a
brief tour right so they're doing um
acute care initially we want them in
that first Co-op to feel warm and cushy
and you start to know
we want them to know where to put your
coat where to put your lunch we want
them to this is this is the hospital
this is the cafeteria this is the EMR
that we use get them oriented to and
have them start to build roots and and
then experience something maybe it's not
something that they love to experience
maybe they're like I want to try
something different well that's the
systems perspective where the aacn is
going is rather than looking at it from
a very siloed perspective let's look at
it from a systems perspective and let's
move those students around a system and
see this in Co-op one student a is in
Med surge maybe they're interested in
critical care let's give them an
experience down in the ICU and that's
part of Emily's job is to move them
around the hospital and work with them
to sort of say where in the end do you
see yourself working Hospital One
hospital system okay right right so
we've had students where have we had
student community so and for Cooperative
tool we actually had them um go to all
the different uh units that were
participating as well as go to the
community so they went to a primary care
and a Specialty Care office to see um is
that for them and we actually put them
in the Ed for an ed observation they did
an O um Cooperative three they're going
to do maternity and PD and then I'm also
going to put them in ICU so they can see
that as well and one of the things that
I'm really excited about so the the
cohort our first cohort is going to
graduate next spring and I anticipate
their orientation to be like super short
and even our nurse Regency program
they're not going to need it all so they
because they've been so uh immersed in
the conquered Hospital culture they're
not going to need to know our Falls you
know precautions and all the things that
they've been doing for three years so
they're going to you're looking forward
to the day when one of the graduates now
becomes a mentor of the next group
aren't we actually have an LNA who um we
did an an LNA program our first round
which uh we actually do have an LNA
apprenticeship program at conquered
hospital that we're trying to get going
because we do need lnas in the field um
and we ended up um she she was brand new
LNA and she's precepting one of the
students and she is so excited and
they're doing great together and it's
like support on both ends because she
can say oh I I'm in the program too and
how can I help you in that way it's
building you know a lot of mentors in
the in the organization of the things I
learned from my training and
counseling is secondary trauma and when
we get people doing a rotation with us I
Shadow them because that new student
especially if this is his or her first
out rotation especially will go into a
room and that first patient will have a
terminal illness that her grandmother
has and you have to be professional but
you can't so defense against what's
going on in you you become cold and
clinical what do you do you don't have
time to figure out what to do because
now your 9:30 is here who is got this
situation which your cousin has and by
the end of the day you're a wreck so
what do you do I debrief them how do you
handle
that so I was going to say that um some
of the interesting things that I saw
last summer with our students is those
again knee knee knocking the very
beginning and in a traditional program
when I was a clinical instructor and if
there was a code that was going on and
the team was working on them I would
stand outside the room with my student
just so that they were out of the way
and I would say and I would explain what
was going on in the room and they were
sort of stepped back this past
summer there was an alert overhead I I
knew it was the students room I knowing
it was the one knee knocking on the
elevator at the beginning I said oh I
better go up there because she's going
to need support she was in the room it
was her patient um it was somebody who
was having a stroke and she identified
the stroke she got her preceptor she got
this she went to the with the patient
down to CT she went with the patient out
to the helicopter because patient had to
be flown to Boston um and then we talked
about it afterwards great job and then
that same student was in a situation
where she was because she was in her LNA
role um
and even in their preceptor their are in
precepted roles were're helping in um
CPR doing chest compressions and doing
the switch where in a lot of cases
nursing students would not be a part of
that but because they feel so
comfortable and the team that they're
with and so comfortable with their
preceptors they're actually a part of
the care that takes place on a
day-to-day basis you're talking now
about the professional actions of the
person I'm talking about their inner
situ
being present y so that um that person
after I found out about the CPR CU I our
clinical faculty who are in the clinical
faculty site say hey we had this student
she had this experience I gave her my
phone number I told her to give me a
call if she needed to it was 9:00 at
night I reached out to her and I said if
you need to talk about this let's talk
about it I saw her again the other part
of our partnership that is really really
um wonderful is that because we are
connected and um have this dual
responsibility and accountability for
these students who are also their
employees they have support from the
wellness center at the college but also
the EAP program at the hospital they
have support from the dean they have the
support from the academic practice
partner who is also their supervisor as
an LNA they have support from their
colleagues from their CCF from their um
classroom faculty their advisors so we
do follow up with them in those
situations to help support them through
like I said the transition shock happens
in that first term in that first
clinical term so we have these
Protections in place to try to help them
navigate through that so that we can
keep them moving forward in the program
so that we can get them on the other end
to graduate so that they can then be
there will be a lessened um transition
shock when they're independent on their
own after graduation I'm so glad to hear
that because I regularly get the comment
from our people rotating through we were
the only facility that has ever done
this with them others will comment on
what they did
professionally I'm the one who talks to
them about your response and triggers
and family and that uh I wish more
places would do that rotational size but
that's just an as side any questions
representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair and also
on a personal note I have a tremendous
amount of respect for the nursing
profession you folks are really the
backbone of our Health Care system and
without you folks who wouldn't exist
thank
you one of the things I look for is the
progression from an LNA to an
RN why stop at the LNA why not allow
them to become an LPN and reason for
that being is once they become an LPN
they start getting a certain sense of
some Independence not completely they
have to work under the RN course and the
care plan but they can do things that
they can't do as an LNA they can start
giving if you will possibly IV drugs
they can start doing certain things of
that capacity it starts helping them on
that journey to Independence so it's a
mid-step between an LNA in a full our
end and still allows them to have that
progression through the professional
years because acquiring the knowledge is
one thing utilization of it in my
opinion is what make the makes them the
professional right so when an academic
MC um perspective I agree that that's an
important that could be an important
step to getting to the RN but from an um
practice side of it so in the hospital
we don't have LPN we do have them in the
outpatient setting um it's it was
explored a little bit during covid but
we we never really gained any traction
there um they are doing if they're going
for ourn they definitely are
participating in those skills it's not
independently it's with your preceptor
so for example like IV medication you
have to have your preceptor or your
faculty with you um so they are getting
those skills but I think it'd be hard to
to find their spot because it would be
more um if we were for the conquered
hospital system we'd have to put them in
the outpatient setting and then they're
not getting as much inpatient prep for
enlex and you you'd have to sit for the
boards
too thank you Mr I totally understand
that part of it is that if you become
the LPN there's no reason why they
couldn't still work inside the hospitals
in LNA and that's really kind of a
Hospital's call what I'm also trying to
get to is it allows them from a pay
scale to earn probably significantly
more money than it would as an LNA which
will keep them going forward versus when
you stay 3 years as an LNA your pay
scale is going to be somewhat diminished
and it's kind of like when you are a
physician you graduate become an intern
you don't work as an LNA you work as a
resident you don't get the same
compensation as you would have
full-blown position if you will um you
know attending if you will or somebody
else Fellowship so I'm just one trying
to get to was the blending of the two
together but it sounds like it's an
internal policy of the hospital not so
much the program yeah I think the
speaking for um from the nhdi adun side
we don't see a lot of LPNs to RN um they
have a program at nhti and it's it's not
very popular they don't get too many
applicants and sometimes they don't even
run it CU we do support that as well
through the um nhti system um but as far
as the academic side yeah they do I mean
they do get the
um they would be able to sit for their
LPN um it's just a matter of through
that employment part of it their scope
of practice if they were working as lnas
their scope they would be working scope
oftice and their scope of practice would
be below their
level if they were an
LPN okay I'm sure you're tracking you
alluded to this
um from graduation of an RN to three
years out to five years out how many
quit and possibly it is because I never
knew it involved this going into it I
thought it was going to college um I'm
going to look forward to your statistics
for people who come through your program
three years out five years out and I'm
going to bet that
the leaving the profession rate is
significantly lower
right yes um there's also retirement
which is a huge issue um there is uh
lack of Faculty like qualified faculty
that sort of creates a problem of how
many students can we take into our
program clinical um site that kind of
limits people to how many students they
can take um and so there are a lot of
different competing things but like I
said that first year of practice for new
I the statistic is clear in my head um
that that 30 to 3 sish depending on what
year you're looking at in practice we
lost um before covid the vacancy rate in
New Hampshire hospitals I believe was
12% RNs and it skyrocketed to 22 2% um
and that's because H we lost so many
nurses during that um transition to burn
out um and working in a covid um
envirment those would be outlier stats
to me I would like to see how many
people graduate this spring in an RN
program where they are in three years
versus how many people graduate through
your kind of program three years out and
if there were even follow-up questions
as to why did you leave well my husband
got sick okay that's not useful here but
to say I didn't know it was like this
that's the gold mine compare contrast
give me a great idea for a study well if
I wanted to go back and get another
degree I'm going to take this one up but
I'm not going to do that any questions
representative King mine isn't a
question and thank you Mr chairman any
comments representative K I have a
comment it's an encouraging comment I I
think we need more of this in all
Industries um 40 some OD years ago maybe
30 uh these this this idea of
apprenticeships seemed to just
disappear and now that um you know the
Baby Boomers are starting to retire
you've already mentioned that
and uh and the the the Millennials are
not uh following suit and some of that
some of that's just because we don't
have the people nurturing and bringing
them into the field so I applaud you for
what you're doing I want to encourage
you that you're on the right track I uh
I also applaud you for looking at uh
different different solutions to a a
severe problem that we have um I was in
for a gallbladder surgery two years ago
and I had to wait a week for a bed to to
become available oh my gosh and um so I
know that there's there are desperate
issues in the hospital and I think this
program is going to be something that's
that will help and it it's going to take
time so be patient thank
you and um that everything seems to come
full circle so we used to have the
conquered Hospital School of Nursing and
I feel like we're getting back to that
where they're so immerse they're ready
this is for me um and I can I'm pretty
excited to track to see how well these
the first cohort and cohorts biano um
and we do track the nurse residency
retainment so I could look up those
numbers and this group compared to other
group will be super interesting to study
any any hopes of bringing back
caps oh I would I'd wear
one okay we do pin though still so all
still night Andale ceremony I mean I
have aunts who are nurses from hospital
school days yep we had a nurse who just
retired last year who wore her cap and
um her skirt every every time she worked
and she was amazing um amazing nurse for
a long time I only say no because it's
it's an
infection
issue representative Merchant thank
you can you speak to with
nhdi I believe there's a 2-year program
for RNs blending that into this program
because in a lot of ways one of the
things I think we see with the 2-year
program is again back to the bedside
knowledge and so forth this sounds like
a great compromise almost going from the
four year to the two- year coming in the
middle is there any thought within the
institutions within New Hampshire
because you have one actually in
Claremont y that would actually blend
the two together and saying you know you
could
become you know a BSN within 3 years
versus going after the As and if you
will then going on to the BSN so the um
NH does your ADN and they actually
partnered with UNH Manchester um it used
to be granet and SN they also have SN
where the um graduate of the ADN program
can actually take courses at SN or UNH
Manchester for associates degree prices
per credit so it Bridges them and then
at conquered um I always try to
encourage them to keep going and what's
really cool about you got your nursing
license you start practicing as an in at
the bedside and you can pluck away at
your nursing classes to get your BSN
because that's a goal of the um I think
it's the American Nurses Association to
have everyone eventually get their
Bachelors um and we actually offer
tuition reimbursement at the hospital
and so I'm like just use your tuition
reimbursement and keep going and you can
work and they'll have more knowledge too
and what's really cool um when they're
in the field I've had I need a project
for My Capstone and oh well I do
I was an orthopedic nurse for 17 years
before I took this role um and I'm like
oh well I have this on the bone program
that we run and wanted to help with
fractured hips and Fracture prevention
and or like we have so many so many
projects for for students and it helps
our organization at the same time um but
we have that and what I would love to
see is um similar to how the NEC program
is some LNA credit towards your nursing
cuz they are
you know for the first five weeks of uh
adjunct I'm an adjunct at nhci we just
are teaching them LNA skills so if they
already have their LNA do we let them in
a little bit later you can uh decrease
their tuition um and our LNA
apprenticeship program like that's
another thing that I think five of my
LNA Apprentice uh want to go back to
school I have a cohort of like 12 right
now um and five of them are like how do
I become a nurse and I'm like well
there's all these different Pathways and
I'd love to like find a way for them to
see where they can go it's nhdi a better
option for me is NC a good option for me
or um and then we hopefully we'll keep
them all of us state legislators are
members of our County's delegations and
most of us are also assigned to one
particular thing guess what I'm on the
County Nursing Home supervisory thing
and would this program not work in a
nursing home as well as a hospital
perhaps it it could but we need to give
them experiences it the system P if they
were a part of a system for sure like
that would make sense for them to have
an experience out in the system but for
those independent nursing homes those
experiences would need to they would be
limited they wouldn't have the
opportunity to go to an ICU or to an ed
or to um they're not going to experience
that same systems perspective um so
observation day though but they could
have an observation day perhaps to go to
a long-term care facility but that would
mean that um observation they would not
be able to participate in Direct Care
outside the scope of practice of an LNA
well I tend to think quite widely not
very deep usually but widely and this in
some permutation might be something to
consider is how can we solve the nurses
lack of thereof in County nursing homes
because we had a shut a w or excuse me a
unit because we can't staff it right and
I made some suggestions about could you
not link up with and that was just a
liberal arts guy thinking without any
specifics you're bringing specifics so
can I bring a liberal arts idea that
maybe
something absolutely absolutely my my
pretty Visionary and I would love
okay more um specific guidelines like
what is it that you would need what's
the scope of the problem um those types
of things but for sure like I would love
to explore how we can help New Hampshire
Healthcare in general um in whatever way
we can we currently have seven partners
and so we have students right now
throughout the state in different
systems who might be connected to a
long-term care facility that we might be
able to impact in some way just like
with the VNA um you know those types of
observations hospice um and paliative
care and those types of experiences
there might be some room for that
sure it sure yeah that's their Capstone
representative Merchant Isn't it nice
when it's just we few
we
intimate is there something we can do
legislatively to help move this along
um a lot of times it comes down to the
money or there may be something you have
to do in statute I don't think there's
anything that I know of within the
regulatory body within the Board of
Nursing but sometimes comes down to is
funding Pilots of funding projects like
this you know is there anything we can
try to do on the legislative side I know
Senator G Ganon put a $300,000 in there
for loan repayment um for nurses for
Primary Care um so those are the things
I'm trying to get to is what can we do
to help Foster this because we
desperately need more nurses right so I
can speak from the academic perspective
and what we might need um New England
college is a private nonprofit so for me
I would I would be curious if there
might be some opportunities for
scholarship money for students um to
come to um NEC to be a part of this
program additionally I have been this
idea has been in the back of my head for
um years I just haven't had time um to
do a a Bea Bea nurse camp in the
summertime to bring Juniors and seniors
from high school to um the college and
um provide them with a couple weeks of
maybe that first course that first
course credit come to
NEC move them around the state go to the
different hospital Partners start to get
to know them explain our model and then
at the same time hopefully um get them
into the role of the LNA and start
moving them forward so potentially there
might be some opportunity for funding
for that program
um and marketing um I have in the past
seen when there was a nursing shortage I
don't even remember how long ago it was
but the Johnson and Johnson Foundation
did a you know a nursing marketing come
into nursing I I have been a New
Hampshire resident now for three years
and I have never and this is this isn't
because maybe it isn't there but I have
not seen that type of like marketing
campaign around being a nurse um stay in
New Hampshire this is what we have to
offer um so that might be something that
you know might be
helpful have you thought about again I
talked about this
before as a profession you folks have a
foot in the door because there're School
nurses how do you engage with a School
nurses get to those Juniors and seniors
to talk about the profession of nursing
because the nurse normally in the school
is again a safe trusted individual is
how do we engage them to help identify
or Foster the marketing if you will for
the students because coming from that
body that individual probably is going
to carry a lot of weight with that
student right absolutely so um one of
the next course that our students are
taking is cooperative 3 and so in that
Cooperative they have the opportunity to
go out into the community in different
ways and it has a um
uh the concepts sort of help them
through women's health issues and also
with Pediatrics and so as part of that
they're going to have some education
around school nursing and what do School
nurses do and as soon as we're able to
partner with a school system we were in
initial talks with Manchester school
system to have our students go out into
the schools and work with School nurses
um we didn't have that set up
necessarily for this co-op in the fall
but but that is the plan in the future
but in this Co-op they'll have the
opportunity to learn about school
nursing and what school nursing
is and conquered Hospital uh has a
program um through conquered High the
crtc program with Sharon bean and she
um I'm new to this role so I she'll give
me a list of students and where they
want to go and what they want to Shadow
and we'll set them up with different
shadows throughout our organization
whether it be outpatient ma LNA um
doctors nurses and just give them that
opportunity and I would love to be able
to give them more opportunity and
there's like a lot of paperwork required
um and I'm thinking of like it's
probably coming from somewhere maybe in
this building I don't know um that we
have to like make sure that they have
all these things and I think we could if
it's hands-off observation we could give
them more um hours that we're able to uh
set them up with different things to
really see what they want to go into and
then um another thing we could look at
is helping the colleges advertise like
you were saying um I know the community
colleges are are struggling with getting
you know enrollment and what does it
look like and I'd love to get like a
pathway for each college and these are
the different colleges and based on
their catchment area or all these
different high schools that we're
working with here's a brochure about how
you can become a nurse and where can you
start and how do you get your feet wet
being an LNA and ma um and even in
cafeteria working and so we have like a
lot of different um opportunities cuz
we're such a big organization that they
could even start in the cafeteria and
then what I've been doing is like hey
what are you interested in you're 16 go
let's set you up with a shadow here or
um even it we' have medical building and
coding students we have a lot of
students um that I'm wrapping my head
around but I I think we could use help
with that um just as like something to
help guide uh younger Generations cuz
it's hard to it's me saying oh there's
NEC there's un there's all these schools
but I don't have anything that really
lays it out for the student what is it
going to look like and how much is it
going to cost me and what's a good way
to go about it do I start as a LNA
Apprentice at conquer Hospital which um
we actually pay for them to go to school
at the hospital um and then they
contract with us for 2 years but I'm
like should should it be two years or if
they're going to school could they drop
back to pum um but because it cost so
much the hospital's like no we want to
be able to make them do it for two years
but I'm like I we also want to be have
them be a nurse so let's let them go to
school and drop back to pum as opposed
to staying full-time so we can make them
successful and then have them as a nurse
later on I'm going to bring this to a
close thank you so much if we have any
more questions you can stick around for
a little while if you have business
cards I'll swap
you thank you and you've all been a
great audience and because of that I'm
going to give you the summer off and we
will reconvene in September although 91a
legal conversations may continue all
through